etienne er ist 67 jahre alt lebt seinen
traum
er lebte seinen traum er hatte ein
deutsches restaurant mitten in den
grünen hügeln von südafrika in eddys
wurstbude bei einheimischen beliebt für
eiswein schnitzel und deutsches bier
die lebte seinen traum bis dieser in
einem blutigen alptraum endete es war
samstagfrüh kurz nach acht als ein
bewaffneter die vor seinem restaurant
überfiel
der räuber forderte geld schleifte dem
wird in dessen büro hatte dann mit einer
machete auf denen das wehrlose opfer ein
die lebensgefährtin margit r konnte sich
flüchten musste aber alles mit ansehen
und dann nur noch die polizei rufen
wir sprechen jetzt mit tommy n dem sohn
von eddie von uns allen erst einmal das
tiefste beileid zum tod ihres vaters
terminal mit der polizei konnten sie
schon sprechen gibt es schon
ermittlungsergebnisse in diesem mordfall
gegen ihren vater
ich weiß dass ein paar handschuhe
wie geht es der freundin ihres vaters
sie musste ja alles mit ansehen konnte
sich in eine nahe gelegene schule retten
und rief da die polizei sich vorstellen
kann im moment sie ist noch tillich noch
immer traumatisiert wir sprechen jeden
tag versuchen die sex alles
weiterzuleiten und weiter zu machen was
jetzt gemacht werden muss aber es ist
natürlich bin ich im moment mit diesen
ganzen carola sache komme ich sagen im
moment da deswegen muss
das im moment sind allein machen
und gott sei dank mithilfe sich darunter
kommt will sie denn wieder zurück nach
deutschland oder bleibt sie in südafrika
dass ich nichts bekommt ich weiß nicht
ich gar nicht wir haben noch gar nicht
gesprochen
auch bekommt man sie legte auch schon
niemand mehr wie die hälfte das leben
ist da unten
es ist noch gar nichts wir wünschen
ihnen hier von bild ganz viel kraft für
diese schwierige zeit die vor ihnen
liegt und noch mal unser tiefstes
empfundenes beileid